- Let's do some more involved
examples using decimals.
So, let's say we wanna
add four and 22 hundredths
to 61 and 37 hundredths.
Like always, I encourage
you to pause the video
and try to figure out on your own.
Well the way that my
brain tries to tackle it,
is it says, alright, I have
four and 22 hundredths,
and 61 and 37 hundredths,
how about I add the four plus the 61,
so it's gonna be four plus 61,
and then separately let
me add the 22 hundredths
to the 37 hundredths,
so then I'm gonna add 22
hundredths plus 37 hundredths,
and so four plus 61 is
going to be equal to 65,
and then 22 hundredths plus 37 hundredths,
well, what's 22 plus 37?
Let's see, 20 plus 30 is 50,
and then two plus seven is nine,
and so it's going to be 59 hundredths.
So 59 hundredths,
so it's gonna be 65 and 59 hundredths,
which we can write as
65 and 59 hundredths.
Now like I've mentioned
in previous videos,
there's many different
ways of adding decimals,
and in future videos we'll learn
arguably faster ways of doing it,
but I wanna show you multiple ways
so you get a sense of ways to approach it,
and this is the way
that I do it in my head
if someone said hey,
something cost $61.37,
and then you had to pay $4.22 in tax,
how much did you have to pay in total,
this is how I would
actually do it in my head,
I would get $65.59.
Let's do another example.
So let's say that we have
three and 53 hundredths,
and we wanna add that to
four and 72 hundredths,
like always, pause this video
and see if you can figure
it out on your own.
So like we did in the previous example,
we can say alright, we could add the ones,
three ones plus four ones,
so it's gonna be three plus four,
and then we could add the hundredths,
and we could say plus 53 hundredths,
plus 53 hundredths,
plus 72 hundredths,
now the three plus four
is pretty straightforward,
that's just going to be ...
Yup, blue color,
this is just going to be equal to seven,
but what is 53 hundredths
plus 72 hundredths?
Well, what's 53 plus 72?
I'm going to write it this way,
this is 53 hundredths, hundredths,
and this is 72 hundredths,
well, three plus two is
going to be equal to five,
and then 50 plus 70 is equal to 120,
so this is going to be 125 hundredths,
125 hundredths,
so how we write 125
hundredths as a decimal
or just as a number?
Well, there's a couple of
ways to think about it,
you could view this as 100 hundredths,
hundredths,
plus 25 hundredths, plus 25 hundredths,
and the reason why I
picked 100 hundredths,
is because 100 hundredths make a whole,
plus 25 hundredths,
and so 100 hundredths
is just going to be one,
so this is going to be
one plus 25 hundredths,
so I could write this one plus 0.25,
and remember, I'm adding
that to the seven here,
so it's gonna be seven,
plus the one, plus the 25 hundredths,
so when we added the 53
hundredths plus the 72 hundredths,
we got 125 hundredths,
which is the same thing
as one and 25 hundredths,
now, the one, we could add in
the ones to the other ones,
and so this is going to be seven plus one,
is equal to eight, eight
and 25 hundredths, so 8.25.
Now, I'm going to
introduce you a little bit
to how people might tackle
this more systematically,
and I want you to think about
how this is the exact same
thing that we just did.
So what you're going to see in the future
is people are gonna say oh
you line up the decimals,
so 3.53 plus 4.72,
and the reason why people
say line up the decimals
is so that you're adding the right places
to the right places, 4.72,
and then they say alright,
we'll just go place by
place and add it up,
which is essentially what we just did
without doing it as
organized of a way here,
and I did it this way
so that you really get
the understanding of what's going on.
But you could say alright,
I have three hundredths
plus two hundredths,
so I'm adding in the hundredths place,
so three hundredths plus two
hundredths is five hundredths,
and then you could say okay, then I have
50 hundredths plus 70 hundredths,
which I did over here,
or you could view this as
five tenths plus seven tenths,
and five tenths and seven tenths
is going to be equal to 12 tenths,
but you can't write 12
tenths in the tenths place,
but what you can do,
so five plus seven is
going to be 12 tenths,
but 12 tenths is the same
thing as one and two tenths,
so you can write the two
tenths in the tenths place,
and then you take the one
and you put it in the ones place,
so five tenths plus seven tenths
is one and two tenths,
and then you add the ones up,
and so you get one plus
three plus four is eight,
so it's eight and two
tenths and five hundredths,
or eight and 25 hundredths, or 8.25,
the exact same thing any way
that you try to tackle it,
but hopefully it makes sense
what's actually going on,
you're adding hundredths to hundredths,
tenths to tenths, ones to ones,
and when, say you add tenths to tenths,
and you get something
that's larger than one,
well, that part that is a whole number,
you can put in the ones place,
and we'll get much much
more practice with this
in future videos.